okay so the full title of this webinar
is new variation services for
normalizing remapping and annotating
variants as I said I'm Peter Cooper from
the customer service part of NCBI you
can certainly write to me Peter Cooper
NIH gov lawn fawn is also here with me
and he's the head of DB step and Rana
Morris is also here to help with the
questions and any technical things that
we have with the webinar so what we're
going to talk about today are these sort
of bullet points here what are the
variants variation services api's we're
going to talk about the variant model
that eight that these api is use it's
called speedy SPD I and I'll spend a few
minutes talking about that and
explaining how that works and then we're
gonna talk about some applications of
the speedy variation services I'll show
you what you can do with them and we'll
just show you an example where you can
see them in action here although they
work behind the scenes here a lot of
ways I'll show you a couple of
interfaces that you can go to to sort of
test them out to play around with them
to see how the how the things work to
show you what kind of results you're
going to get back and then I'll do some
live practice using those interfaces and
I'll go to the command line as well and
show you a demonstration script that
will show you how to access them using a
script and then we'll course will have
questions at the end okay so what are
these things the variation services API
this is a set of your ala based or
restful programming interfaces for
accessing and working with variation
data NCBI as I said they rely on this
new variation representation called
speedy which stands for sequence
position deletion insertion variation
services and speedy are used internally
at NCBI to the NDB snip and clinvar and
it's how we manage them to deal with
these large numbers of variants that are
present in both of those resources
okay so I'll talk a little bit about the
variant model for the next few minutes
the simple representation that uses a
sequence ID that's what the sequence
part is the location and the alleles a
deletion take something out and search
and you put something back
these are gonna represent variants with
precise coordinates they're much easier
for very normalization and we'll talk a
little bit about what I mean by that in
a few minutes they're designed to be
machine readable although people can
figure out what they mean as wells
explain why they're a little more
machine readable than people readable in
just a minute
they're amenable to high performance
computation which is why we use them
internally at NCBI for sequence variant
processing and you can represent both
nucleotide sequences and protein
sequence variants but at the bottom of
this slide there are some URLs that will
take you to a web document about
speaking notation which is helpful but
much more helpful and much more detail
is the preprint that's available on bio
archive and there's a link to it there
on the bottom of the slides if you want
to know more about this variant model
that's the place to go to find out all
about it ok so here's an example of a
variant that's shown in speedy notation
and this is sort of a linear form of
this and as you can see also on the
slide there's a structured format
adjacent a JavaScript object format or
the speedy which is what the api's are
going to return to you basically a
sequence ID this is a reference sequence
for chromosome 8 a position in that
reference sequence then there is a base
that's deleted in the base that's
inserted and notice that the speedy
variant model doesn't require that you
have the deleted base there you can just
use the length of the base and that
brings me to the next point on this
slide which is that speedy uses and this
is the part that makes them a little
tricky to read for people it uses a
zero-based coordinate system and it's an
inter base one so basically the the
insertion deletion starts between bases
one i-81 nine seven two and one nine
eight one nine seven three it's the
space between those bases so the G
that's being deleted is the G at
position one nine eight one nine seven
three and the one base called sequence
coordinate system and so the advantage
of this from a computational point of
view is that you can actually represent
a pure insertion with
Varian length of zero and here's the
corresponding example of a speedy
notation for a protein variant again
written both ways with deleted sequence
base or the deletion length and again
you can get this as an object a
structured format from the API now we
use speedy behind the scenes and the
variant services behind the scenes in
the variation services variation
databases and resources at NCBI if you
want to see them alive and in person in
action here's a place where you can see
that the variant search in clinvar uses
speedy and so if you've searched clinvar
with HTTP nomenclature recently you'll
see these kinds of things they let you
know that you might have a variant
that's not in clinvar and it will then
it will map you to DV snip or there
might be an equivalent variant that's
present in clinvar and it will link you
to that variant so what can you do with
these variation services sort of three
things you can do you can normalize your
variant and that means finding the
equivalent one and ncbi DB snip and
clinvar variants transform your data so
convert formats so if you have a speedy
you can get the HTTP and vice-versa and
then you can do all these kinds of
things to standardize the way your
variants are shown you can correct for a
left or right shifting for insertions
and deletions and we'll talk a little
bit more about that and then when we
talk about contextual alleles you can
transform your data into right shifted
HGVs or less just as VCF which is a
preferred way of writing them very
useful thing you can do is to remap your
sequence variant and so that uses our
alignment database system to allow you
to map variance between assemblies
between various kinds of sequences that
are in there it also gives you access to
annotations because you can access the
snip records in a structured format and
those records are going to include
functional consequences or little
frequency clinical significance and all
kinds of other important information
about the variant a couple of terms that
we're going to come across today
that I'm gonna mention one of them is
the idea of a contextual léo element of
say that one first these are sort of
alphabetical on this slide so a
contextual is a unique normalized
representation that is corrected for
something called over precision oh and
over precision is pretty easy to
understand if you look at a portion of
DNA for example that has a low
complexity region or repeat in it if you
look at these examples shown at the
bottom of the slide you can think about
a deletion and you see those ga-ga
repeats there if I remove one of those
GA s
it doesn't matter which one I remove I'm
gonna wind up with the same sequence
result and so really over specifying
which one of those I use is what's
called over precision the problem with
that is it can give rise to things that
look like different variants when
they're in fact not different variants
and it's one of the things that speedy
has been very helpful for because it
corrects for these kinds of things the
other thing that I want to mention is
this canonical representative allele or
a representative record that you can see
and this is a really useful thing to do
with the variation services it'll allow
you to map to a particular sequence
model and the thing that we call the
canonical allele is usually based on the
latest genomic assembly such as grch38
so if you wanted to map a allele on a
different sequence to the standard a
wheel in grch38 you can do that using
the variation services so this is just a
slide that shows you how you can do
these kinds of things in sort of a
schematic you've got all these different
variants in different formats you
convert them to a speedy in particular
you want to try to get the contextual
alleles and those are going to normalize
for overly precision overly precise
variants correct and you can correct all
your problems to make your VCF and your
HTTP compliant with sort of the
standards and then you can also remap
these using the alignment data based
system into there is genome builds and
things like that
here's a couple of simple examples of
sort of normalization or standardizing
your variance so at the top of this
slide I have an HGVs name for a variant
and it's written as an insertion so
insert two keys I can convert that using
the speedy services to a speedy
contextual allele and this is an
unambiguous representation of this
particular variant then I can convert
that back into HTTPS on all these
different reference sequences and the
preference is to make this represent it
as a duplication rather than an
insertion there you can see the the
correct way or the preferred way of
writing these as a duplication this is a
more complicated example first of all
you'll notice that the HGVs expression
contains a GenBank accession number here
and that's the brca2 mrna because the
alignment database system has some of
the insdc or GenBank sequences in it
aligned to all our other reference
sequences and things like that and so
this is written as a deletion and it's
actually the left shift at HTTPS which
means that the the deletion is shown
sort of at the left hand side of where
this variant could be because this is a
problem because this is a repeat
sequence I can turn this into a unique
representation called a speedy
contextual allele and I can normalize
the HTV s that way and so then I will
get back to a right shift it's shown at
the right-hand end of that insertion
deletion and I can of course get back
all the different connection alleles and
all the HGVs expressions and of course
I'm mapping it to chromosome 13 here in
this watch okay
so how do you do this if you were doing
it with a program or a script you could
use the API which is a URL based system
there's a base URL that's written for
you there the services you can use that
take various kinds of input they take
speedy HGVs VCF and you can get back the
reference snip records using this
riffs of service and there's some
example URL calls you can try those out
yourself writing your web browser if you
want to and I won't click on them here
because we'll do some live examples here
in just a couple of minutes one thing
that when the developers wanted me to
point out is that the v-0 URLs will be
stable and backwards compatible so you
don't need to worry about changing that
so here's a full list of the services
and functions and these would be the
things that you would add on the end of
that URL there are two demonstration
interfaces there's a simple web demo and
an API documentation interface and I'm
going to show you both of those I'll
show you how they work the simple demo
interface which is if this URL here just
go to variation slash services slash
demo and you can put any HTTP expression
in there you want this happens to be the
one for the fairly famous CFTR Delta 508
deletion and I can take that single HTTP
that I can do all the things that speedy
services do for the most part so I can
get the speedy representation I can get
the identifiers here that will give me
the link to the ref snip record I can
get the normalized HGVs which in this
case is the same and I can map it to all
these other sequences here that are
available the other interface which is
useful in particular if you're going to
start writing software that accesses
this is the swagger documentation of the
API and it lets you see the full API
response and these are the various
services here you can expand these and
you can try them out so here's an
example where I can put in the HTTP like
I did before and I can run this to try
it out and get back speedy the same one
that I got a few minutes ago on the the
simple interface but now it comes back
in the structured format so it's going
to show you the header and everything
else it also gives you the request URL
that you could use to get this and a
curl command line so if you wanted to
try this out on your command line to
test it out you could do that okay so
just to wrap this part up the main point
here is you know these are
raishin interfaces you're really going
to want to be accessing these using
software and L'Enfant has put up some
tutorials up on a github site the NCBI
get up site and that's the URL that will
take you there there are a bunch of
tutorials here about how to manage the
JSON format from DB snip there's also a
set of variation services demonstrations
here including a jupiter notebook that
shows you how the calls work and a real
simple script in python then will let
you access things via the api okay so
what i hope we have time to do now is to
try to do a couple of demos the first
ones i'm going to do are going to be
using the variation services we're going
to the web interfaces we're going to
writing to the side a few variants are
the same and then I'll show you the
Python demo script from get up and we
can show you how that runs on the
command line if we have time here so let
me go ahead and back out of my slides
I'm gonna go over to a web browser what
I want to do is to go ahead and take the
two variants that we showed in our
slides a few minutes ago and if I I have
made myself a little cheat sheet that's
available on the FTP site and so the two
variants that we're going to use or here
so here is our first variant which is
written as 27 doopty notice that I can
also write this as an insertion which is
the not preferred way and so I'm going
to use that one when we run this the
other thing I have is the VCF line here
that has another variant that looks
quite different what we want to do is to
see if these two things are the same so
what I can do here is go to the simple
interface here paste my PCF
and run this so it gives me the speedy
representation it gives me a link to DV
snip this is a variant that causes beta
thalassemia there's a normalized HTTP or
return that insertion variant into a
duplicate variant which is the way we
want to prefer to have written and
here's a map Dover to all the other
sequences that we have available here
now what we want to do to find out if
these are really the same variant is we
want to map them to that canonical
representative and that's going to be
this one here if we turn it into a speii
so I'm gonna go ahead and do that gonna
grab that and put that up here and so
this is our speedy representation of
that particular variant okay now what we
want to do is to see if we get the same
speedy representation for HGVs allele so
what I'm gonna do is now go to the
variation services swagger documentation
which is over here and we're going to
compare the representation that we get
for that allele that's shown in the VCF
so let me go over here I can expand any
one of these I want for example if I
wanted to try to get that to run that
HGVs expression hit the speedy I could
do that here and that's in my demo if
you want look at this script but I'm not
going to do that just to save some time
because we've already done that and
we've seen how that works so what I want
to do is to get the contextual allele
from the VCF that we have here so let me
get that open
so what we want to do is try it out okay
so we want to put a chromosome now you
don't have to have the accession number
here which we don't have so the thing
that we're working with is over here so
we've got chromosome 11 sorry wrong one
we need our position we need our ref a
and are all which is AC and I think I
can remember that let's see if I do now
what we don't have is the correct
assembly here we need to know the
assembly because we need to do we only
have here is for chromosome 11 it's okay
assembly that I want to use is 25 may
verify that that's the one that was in
my notes over here that's 20 40 no 525
and so there's my speedy it's returned
to me as a Jason but it's the same one
that we found before so these two
alleles are the same alleles so we
verified that by using speedy and that's
the same kind of thing that we do here
at NCBI
to verify these okay the last thing I'm
just going to touch on is to show you
the github site and maybe it will run
one or two examples from that on the
command line so let me go over there my
cheat sheet I have the github site here
so here are the tutorials that are
working with this DB snip Jason here are
the variation services that we can use
today to do that and notice that there
is a jupiter notebook there's also this
python script it's a simple Python
script but it gives you a good starting
point if you want to write your own
little script to access creation
services and there's also some
demonstration files that you can do to
run this so I'm gonna go ahead and load
the Spidey batch Python here just so you
can see the code and the reason is
because it's got these nice little
command lines that are those things that
you can run as an example so I'm going
over here to terminal window
then I've got Spidey batch Python in
here and I've got some other files that
I can work with so let's do a couple of
things here so I have a VCF file in
there
so let's do that one and this is one
that I didn't demonstrate on the web
interface but it's a pretty handy thing
to be able to do so here's a VCF and
it's just so you know ahead of time this
is mapped on grch37 but what we don't
have is an ID column there and what we
can do with this particular part of the
script is we can go ahead and put the RS
IDs in there so here's a command line
that will do that
and I'm just pacing these ends that you
don't have to watch me type okay so now
we can see we have rest snip identifiers
notice that a couple of these variants
do not have riffs that by identifiers
and it lets you know that which is a
useful thing and so you could go ahead
and try out some of these other examples
if you want on your own it's just a
simple one and so you can take any kind
of file that you want and I've got those
available I'll make them available on
our FTP site if you want to do exactly
the command lines that are in my hand
out here and included in there is a way
to download the JavaScript objects and
things like that but I think we should
stop at this point and see if there are
any questions that we need to answer
they probably have a few of them now
milette Ronna ron has been sort of
collating the questions and we can have
her read them and then we can answer
them hi there are a whole bunch of
questions we'll take all the questions
the relevant questions that have come in
create a QA document and over the next
week make sure we have detailed answers
to every single question that's come in
and we'll post that in the FTP site that
I actually chatted out to you the first
one I think is kind of important for all
of NCBI variation services at this point
one of the people specifically asked
about using this particular service with
non human genetic variation data in
particular he was interested in dog I'm
gonna let lon answer that question lawn
Pam that's right you know we ain't doing
along and support non-human organisms
variation but we are also looking at
refactoring some of these services like
the remapping service and that's a
separate function essentially or utility
and so Basu Mele then you know you could
just provide any type of alignment
status set and it would work for any
organism so if there's something
interests you now when we get your
feedback from the service feedback that
you will send out just comment on there
you know what you would like to see this
work for go ahead put you know where
your wish lists on there and will be
considered and prioritize with our other
tasks or another workload so thank you
next question actually I'm going to
combine to somebody asked whether or not
this service is actually open source are
there any licensing or use requirements
and another person asked what are the
volumes scalability limits of these
services what kind of batches can be
used can you do hundreds of thousands of
variances as an example so one open
source to licensing and three use yes
this is all open source there's no
license required it just we just have
the basic disclaimer of the NCI data and
that and in terms and what's the other
one the volume right now like it we're
we're still sort of in the testing mode
so go ahead and try it out and we also
will have some of the questions
regarding volume in our survey again
respond to that and that will help us
plan in terms of scaling up if you need
it thank you another user asked can
these services be run on private servers
or infrastructures again we are
considering having a some of these thing
run offline on your today I said you can
run your own data set online and so with
that something we look at planning in
the future refactoring a lot of these
functions that it's run like a utility
offline again if you can just respond to
the survey did you wish lists on there
okay okay now we're gonna get a little
more into the data one of the users said
the ref snip service is listed as still
being in beta testing mode when will the
final version be released the ref LePage
is actually live now it's actually the
final version I think the alpha label
I've been removed on that page within
the last week so it'll still be in
development continuous device yeah yeah
exactly will continue improve based on
user feedback so if you got anything you
want to just go ahead write the help
desk a little try prioritize it okay
someone is really interested in mapping
alleles over to the cleansing registry
alleles using the contextual alleles is
that possible and I think Lin you may
want to discuss clinvar at that point
yes so right now we're not integrated
with the little register the little
register yet but I think it's something
we could discuss with their developers
right now there were they integrate DB
snip data I
it's part of what they could you know
provide we could provide all the
contextual alleles and then it would
make available for the new to normalize
it from with the little registry alleles
now formatting a user was interested in
posting a speedy JSON representation is
that possible for posting in JSON format
purposes so if you go to our API the
variant service page some of the
function would support post function and
others who will not again if you need
other functions of posts again just put
it as the feature request in a survey
and again we'll look at it Peter you may
have a slide that you can show for this
now we're talking about VCS as an input
file and they wanted to know if you're
going to put in a VCF input file for
let's say a speedy batch how would you
specify the build itself let's say they
they want to actually do an a search on
build grch38 as opposed to 37 so in the
you have to pass the I think in your
lawn can correct me on this but I think
you have to pass the assembly accession
number a there is a parameter for you to
pass the assembly accession number
number so that we'll know which some of
you referring to for the each of the
chromosome and that example I didn't
point it out and I meant to let me see
if it's still there let me escape from
this for a moment should be still there
and I think on that example it should
show you the URL and I should have
pointed that out this is the new the
newly released site so it looks a little
different but if you see this this URL
here where I passed the VCF fields here
so here was a chromosome 11 there's a
position there is the variant you're
using this service that gets you the
contextual we're passing the assembly as
this assembly accession number and so
you would need the assembly accession
number for grch37 which this one happens
to be the assembly accession number for
each 37 if you look at the speedy batch
Python script that's on github that
Peter demonstrated if you look at the
code is the version it's passed an
example in there right in fact that's
the example that I ran in that
particular case
that Python script is fairly simple so
it has the assembly accession encoded in
it but you could easily modify it so
that you could you could give it the
assembly accession number all right it's
it's after 12:30 so there are a couple
of other questions that are very very
specific and technical with regard to
the speedy format and they're interested
in understanding the rationale behind
some of that we will actually write that
up in the QA document so that you have a
better and a fuller understanding of
that bio archive paper that's linked in
that slide has explains a lot about the
speedy rationale and details about how
it works to make those contextual
alleles so I suggest you check that out
because that may answer your question it
depends of what it is but we'll
definitely get the answer in the
document that we put up ok so I think
we're gonna wrap it up and thank you all
very much for coming we're going to go
ahead and sign off now